imagine you're wearing a thin layer of
clothing and you're suddenly dropped 40
ft into freezing cold water it's the
stuff of nightmares right well now
imagine you're doing it as an actor in a
billion dooll movie franchise any better
well maybe a little but probably not
much freezing is freezing people and
this is a scenario Daniel Radcliffe and
Emma Watson had to deal with while
filming some of the Harry Potter movies
today I'm diving into one of the most
uncomfortable scenes they filmed as well
as a couple of other source spots
literally that the cast had to endure
before we get into the freezing cold
water let's talk a little about the
freezing cold air and by that I mean
filming the Quidditch scenes and no they
didn't actually send the cast way up
into the cold English air to film they
had green screens for that but one thing
they didn't have green screens for were
the brooms the Wizards all rode while
playing quidditch those props were
strictly functional and were basically
just brooms and while you might think
they came fitted with some extra
cushiony seat for the rear ends of all
the actors that apparently was not the
case according to Daniel Radcliffe
filming the Quidditch scenes ranked near
the top of his list of things he didn't
enjoy while filming in a 2009 press
conference Daniel said quote it is not a
pleasant experience it does hurt quite a
lot and it is not something I would be
rushing back to do in fact Radcliffe
even joked that his favorite aspect of
filming the seventh movie was that there
was no quidditch scenes so his bum
remained unbruised at least as far as I
know so while Daniel may have gone into
the filming of the final movie feeling
great about a lack of quidditch scenes
he was about to get a lot more
uncomfortable as were Emma and rert
Grint there's a scene towards the end of
the movie where the three of them are
carried by a dragon out of gring guts
but instead of a gentle landing on say
land the kids are dropped into a lake
from quite a high distance but it wasn't
even the drop or getting soaked that
made the day uncomfortable it was the
fact that the lake itself was freezing
and because of the schedule of filming
the next scene the actors weren't
allowed to wear anything under their
costumes to protect them I mean you'd
think not giving actors hypothermia
would Trump scheduling but hey what do I
know said Emma quote the lake wasn't
heated and because we had to get changed
as part of the next scene we couldn't
wear anything underneath I was lucky I
had my bottom half with some thermals on
but I was like this must be a joke it
was so cold she also mentioned that rert
was so cold that he at one point thought
his heart had stopped beating so yeah
the lake was like heart-stoppingly cold
not too surprising that Emma Daniel and
rert had a miserable day of filming Emma
cites this as her least favorite day on
set and I can see why of course it
wasn't the only time Daniel had to deal
with the complexities and physical
rigors of filming in water heck the guy
seemed to be underwater a lot of the
time especially for a movie about
Wizards flying through the air right in
the halfblood prince he and Michael
Gambon AKA Dumbledore have to fight
against Undead Corpses known as INF
faery the battle is in a dark
water-filled cave and apparently the
process was not ideal for Daniel in an
interview in 2022 he reminisced on the
shoot saying they had him hold onto a
wire while he was holding his breath
underwater then when they called action
he was yanked quite hard out of the
water of course since the surface of the
cave water was supposed to be on fire at
the same time he had to ascend into that
said Daniel quote so I flew out of the
water and there was like a ring of fire
around me so I would just like bursting
out of the surface of the water through
a ring of fire sounds like fun of course
nothing can top the amount of underwater
filming Radcliffe did for the famous
Wizarding tournament in Goblet of Fire
one of the challenges involved him and
the other competing Wizards trying to
rescue their friends from underwater
traps that meant hours and hours of
getting footage of them underwater
Daniel wasn't already scuba certified so
first he had to endure 6 months of
training before they started filming
then came the hard part they filmed a
total of 41 hours of footage of him
underwater and unless you happen to have
gills that's a lot of time underwater he
ended up with serious ear infections on
two different occasions and according to
Daniel they only used about 7 Seconds a
day of the footage they got but
ultimately he felt it was the right
decision he said quote there was a lot
of talk of someone else doing it and
superimposing my face on it that would
have looked like rubbish for Emma Watson
the grueling parts of filming the Harry
Potter series made it a difficult
process and she actually considered
leaving the production all together at
one point as did rert Grint and Daniel
Radcliffe though apparently they never
shared that fact with one another until
years later for Emma it was in large
part because of the loneliness she felt
while filming especially because she was
missing out on school and being around
her friends from home but at the same
time Emma was able to reexamine the
challenges of filming in a more positive
light later on when doing press for her
movie Noah in 2014 she talked about how
the rigors of filming Harry Potter
prepared her well she says that she
doesn't expect any filming to be as
difficult as the Harry Potter production
and that quote I'm pretty prepared for
most things people can throw at me
whether it be animals water stunts CGI
whatever it is so despite having a tough
time getting through it all she clearly
came out the other side feeling the
benefits even Radcliffe ultimately had
good things to say about the grueling
process he talked about how there are a
lot of things from filming that he would
never want to do again but that at the
same time he said quote it was one of
those moments you look back and you go
God that's special okay so now that you
know all about the torture these actors
went through for filming I bet you
wouldn't trade places with them cuz
besides their Fame Fortune talent and
good looks they really don't have that
much going for them okay okay maybe we
would all vote to trade lives with
Daniel and Emma but that doesn't make
filming those scenes any easier so Props
to them for getting through it have any
thoughts about the filming of the Harry
Potter movies pop them in the comments
section